à cette coiffeuse on travaille l'image
de soi une étape pour l'aide à
l'insertion l'une des missions de
l'unité éducative d'activité de jour de
villepreux
notre directeur interrégional c'est
simon a souhaité il ya quelques années
que la sete
ce lieu de villepreux soit rénové et
réorienter vers un lieu d'insertion mais
spécifiquement en prenant en compte
l'ensemble de ce qu'on appelle la santé
au global c'est à dire le bien-être 24
jeunes de 16 à 18 ans peuvent être reçus
en continu un accompagnement
individualisé proposé par sept personnes
dont trois éducateurs et deux
psychologues
je met en place des ateliers comme de la
boxe thérapeutique des ateliers de
relaxation
je peux aussi être avec mes collègues
sur des ateliers de valorisation de soi
sur les groupes des changes aussi qu'on
fait avec en partenariat avec une
éducatrice des photos langage la vidéo
voilà et des espaces de parole par an
sais tu agis est l'un des cinq
établissements et blinois de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
la pjj dépend du ministère de la justice
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
prend en charge effectivement des
mineurs délinquants mais prend également
en charge des mineurs sous protection
judiciaire des mineurs qui peuvent être
pris en charge en protection de
l'enfance et à ce titre nous travaillons
avec le conseil départemental qui est le
chef de file de la protection de
l'enfance actuellement la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse des yvelines
prend en charge environ 800 jeunes